معنا من حيفا ايهاب جبارين الكاتب المختص
في في الشان الاسرائيليه الامريك سيد
ايهاب ليست عمليه الاغتيال الاولى ابتداء
من الشيخ ياسين الجعبري الرنتيسي ايضا
رائد عطار كانت كل هذه العمليات لها وقع
بالتاكيد على المقاومه كونهم قاد بارزون
ولكن لم يكن لها تاثير على استمراريه
المقاومه بل كانت تزداد قوه كل يوم
بالتالي هل يمكن ان يكون لاغتيال العاروري
ثير على ما تقوم به المقاومه وعلى
قراراتها التي اعلنها العاروري منذ يوم
السابع من
اكتوبر نعم تحياتي مياد و صباح الخير
بطبيعه الحال هنا يجب ان ناخذ بعين
الاعتبار ان اسرائيل في كل ما تقوم به من
عمليات عاده تاخذ مفهوم الثمن مقابل
المردود المردود هنا واضح لكن الثمن
باعتقادي هو غير واضح لاسرائيل او على
الاقل يعني هي غمر في كل جزئيه الثمن يعني
بكل تاكيد اخذت من سوف يكون هنالك مردود
ومنتوج اكبر بكبير مما تعتقد فاتوره يجب
عليها دفعها بكل عمليه الاغتيال هذا الامر
وارد ولكن هنا ربما يجدر الاشاره الى
السؤال الذي كان قد سئل في التقرير اي ايا
من على ماذا تراهن اسرائيل هل تراهن
على طموحات بنيامين نتنياهو ان تكون هنالك
اشعال للمنطقه وبالتالي حبل جا من كل ما
ينتظره في نهايه هذا المطاف ام ان ايه على
المطا يعني هذا على بالنسبه لبنم نتنياهو
لكن كذلك هنالك انا باعتقادي ان ما راهن
عليه
المستوى العسكري والاستخباراتي والامني
تحديدا هنا قبل اي شيء اخر انا باعتقادي
هو راهن على الجهود الدبلوماسيه للولايات
المتحده وا يعني قطعا انا لا اعتقد بان
الولايات المتحده لم تكن تعرف بهذه
العمليه البته ولا حتى يعني قبل نصف ساعه
كما اشير او حال وقوعها بل باعتقادي ان
هنالك شراكه تامه في جهاز الاستخباراتي ما
بين
البلدين وبالتالي على هذا تحديدا كانت
تراهن اسرائيل الامنيه والاستخبارات بان
هنالك يكون لحظه تصعيد بالذات الحديد
الحديث هنا ان قواعد اللعبه وقواعد
الاشتباك مختلفه كليا في داخل ال لبنان
فبالتالي هي تكون فرصه لكي تنزل من على
الشجره المتواجده والرمال المتحركه المتو
فيها في داخل القطاع تنزل من على تلك
الشجره في شجره اخرى لكن بدون ادنى شك ان
هنالك قواعد اللعبه مختلفه والمساعد
الدبلوماسيه سوف تاخذ حيزا على هذا يراهن
باعتقادي المستوى الامني والاستخباراتي
بان الجهود الدبلوماسيه تاخذ حيزا
وبالتالي ينتهي هذا الازمه بالذات بان
المستوى العسكري حتى الان مازال يسال ما
هي الاهداف السياسيه لكل هذه الحرب ان كان
ما تقوله سيد ذهاب هو ما جرى بالفعل ان
الولايات المتحده كانت شريكا في هذا هذا
القرار باغتيال العاروري بالتالي اليس ذلك
ياتي ضمن نطاق المغامره بتوسيع نطاق الحرب
وجر المنطقه لتون حرب
اوسع هذا بالتالي هذا ياخذنا الى ما يامل
به بنيامين نتنياهو كذلك يجب ان نتذكر ان
بنيامين نتنياهو يعني الشخص الذي اشعل
اسرائيل على مدى خمس سنوات وادخلها ودمرها
بمفهوم كهذا او كاخر وادخلها في ازمه قياض
كي يلوذ بنفسه من الفرار هل حقا يابه بان
ياخذ المنطقه كليا ويجر حتى معه الولايات
المتحده في داخل ازمه كهذه لكي يلوذ بنفسه
لذات الاسباب بالذات الفض وربما حتى الان
هنالك الحديث عن نجان تحقيق طبعا بطبيعه
الحال هذا ما يعمله بنيامين نتنياهو لكن
يجب ان نتذكر ان هنالك صراع حقيقي ما بين
الاداره الامريكيه وما بين حكومه بنيامين
نتنياهو الحاليه طبعا الواضحه والجليه
للعيان فبالتالي انا باعتقادي ان كذلك
الاداره الامريكيه في ضون كل هذه الم
مرحله تحاول ان تاخذ بنيامين نتنياهو
بعيدا عن كل ما قال الصراع والوحل المتحرك
في داخل القطاع يجب ان نتذكر ان منذ
الاسابيع الاولى عندما كان هنالك النفير
الامريكي الى داخل المنطقه الولايات
المتحده حاولت ان تعمل لذات الاسباب التي
ذكرناها سابقا ان ان تحافظ على اسرائيل من
هوس بنيامين نتنياهو هذا ما عمل عليه
بايدن انذاك وكذلك كل الشركاء الامريكيون
لكن الان هم يرون بان اسرائيل متوغل في
داخل الرماء المتحركه لذات الدوافع التي
نخاف منها في البدايه فبالتالي واضح جدا
انهم سوف يحاولون يعني اخذ هذه المساعي
الى مساع اخرى الى جبهات اخرى لكي يحاولوا
ان يخفضوا من وطه كل ما يجري في داخل
القطاع الذي الامر الذي بات يحرج الاداره
الامريكيه اكثر فاكثر ويجب ان نتذكر ان
هنالك حلبه صراع حقيقيه ما بين الاداره
الامريكيه وحكومه بنيامين نتنياهو من يذهب
الى الانتخابات اولا يخسر انا باعتقادي ان
الاداره الامريكيه تحاول ان ان ان تنهي
حاله وحاله العدوان الحاليه لكي تجور
اسرائيل الى انتخابات مبكره تكون ما قبل
الانتخابات الامريكيه شكرا جزيلا لك من
حيفا ايهاب جبارين الكاتب المختص في الشان
الاسرائيلي